Avatar the way of water had its official
premiere on December 6th and the First
Reactions are making their way to social
media it will be a little over a week
before the public has their chance to
sit in the theater but we're getting a
good sense of what to expect when that
day comes James Cameron had a lot on his
plate regarding the follow-up but the
director certainly isn't afraid of a
challenge he has serious plans to
continue the Avatar franchise if
everything goes well for the way of
water and moviegoers are happy so are
they happy here are the biggest
takeaways from Twitter regarding the
second avatar movie there really was no
doubt was there early reactions to the
second pandorian flick as members of the
press all saying the same thing I've
never seen anything like this in a movie
comicbook.com's Brandon Davis summed it
up when he tweeted Avatar the way of
water is a never-ending visual spectacle
the stunning visuals were a major theme
and early reactions to the film a
Brock's writer Mike Ryan highlighted the
movie's visuals perfectly tweeting yeah
never bet against James Cameron trying
to spare hyperbole but I've never seen
anything like this from a technical
visual standpoint it's overwhelming
maybe too overwhelming sometimes I'd
miss plot points because I'm staring at
a Pandora fish well there you have it
finding a tweet about the way of water
that didn't mention the visuals was like
trying to find a needle in a haystack
Eric Davis a Fandango tweeted happy to
say Avatar the way of water is
phenomenal bigger better and more
emotional than Avatar the film is
visually breathtaking visceral and
Incredibly engrossing the story The
spectacle the spirituality the beauty
this is movie making and storytelling
and its absolute finest a theme among
those lucky enough to preview the film
is that the film looks great when the
scene is set on land but the underwater
moments are going to knock your socks
off as for the story most of the early
reactions suggest the way of water is
well-rounded for the most part many
suggested the story is engaging and Upsy
ante Tessa Smith the Mama's geeky wrote
it delivers on both action and heart
while giving fans an intriguing story
that feels earned and warranted Sean
O'Connell of Cinema Blend added
incredible visuals but a much more
emotional connection to the characters
and story on the other end of the
spectrum those who had issues with the
story felt it was a little mad to say
the least as Ian Sandwell of Digital Spy
tweeted it does suffer from a thin story
and too many characters to juggle yet
James Cameron pulls it together for an
extraordinary Final Act full of emotion
and thrilling action one person
mentioned the film clocking in at over
three hours saying that runtime ain't no
walk in the park and it will turn off
some the reactions that criticized the
movie were few and far between so don't
put too much stock into them for all
accounts James Cameron has another
winner on his hands we'd be hard-pressed
to name a director who does sequels
better than James Cameron and he's
making it more evident than ever with
the way of water pairing nemeroff of
collider said I had Faith James Cameron
would raise the bar with the effects but
these visuals are mind-blowing one
stunning frame after the next but the
thing I dug most is how the technical
Feats always feel in service of
character and World building I went to
the studio and I said let's not just do
another movie Let's swing for the fences
she suggested a second viewing would
help iron things out for the viewer
something Cameron is no doubt banking on
sharing the same sentiments on Cameron
and his attention to detail was happy
sad confused podcast host Josh Horowitz
who wrote James Cameron once again shows
filmmakers how it's done I've said it a
thousand times never doubt him Avatar
the way of water is how you do epic
blockbustering emotional visceral and as
big as movies get looks like the way of
water is the sequel we were all hoping
for
foreign
[Music]